Soon, very soon you're going to have
a similar story that you can share with
your friends and family.
Hi, I'm Jessica Allman, and I'm going to
be here to help you walk through
the process of building
an app from scratch.
Now, this course is going to be
a little bit different than what
you've previously experienced
in Udacity courses.
For one, you've already got the
technical traps to build this app, but
you might need a little bit more
help with maybe a processor or
method for doing so.
And, that's what I'm here for.
So, to do so, we're going to be
asking you a series of questions,
to help you start kind of
thinking like a developer and
asking questions that
they would be asking.
And we hope that you really do think
about and answer these questions,
recording your answers either
in a blog or on the forums.
Or if you're a little shy and
don't want to post it publicly,
maybe in a handy notebook or
on your own computer.
Let's take a look at how
we're going to build an app.